[Music]
what is code before we can answer that
we should answer an easier question
what's a computer a computer is a clock
with benefits they all work the same
doing second grade math one step at a
time
take take a signal and put it in box one
tick take another signal put it in box
two tick combine the signals in box one
and maybe add them together and subtract
you using a pen and paper can do
anything a computer could do you just
can't do those things billions of times
per second that speed makes it possible
to pull multiple slights of hand all at
once card tricks on top of card tricks
code is a means of harnessing the
computer's power setting up all those
card tricks it all starts with words and
characters entered into a computer by a
human using a keyboard they're writing
in a programming language a programming
language is really just a set of rules
it tells you which words you can use to
tell the computer what you needed to do
take a look at this code tin JavaScript
it's a very common language that turns
the webpage from a document that looks
like nonsense into software many
webpages Amazon for instance are packed
with software code like this there's
code all through here code that makes
the page into something dynamic now
javascript is just one of thousands of
languages that ultimately all do the
same thing they make the computer go so
why does it matter which you choose for
the same reason that you don't take a
bicycle to buy a fridge or get a
physical from a neurosurgeon some
languages just match up better with
certain problems C++ is something you
might use if you were building a game
for the playstation or xbox PHP is code
for creating millions of webpages they
use it at Etsy and Facebook Python is a
great general-purpose language it's used
by Instagram and a lot of scientists so
you know a computer is a clock with
benefits and we know you can use a
programming language to make software
but how does that actually happen well
the computer takes the programming code
and reads through it
character by character tosses out all
the spaces tabs comments and other stuff
it leaves behind what a computer
scientist might call tokens
once it has tokens the computer does the
digital equivalent of burrowing its brow
and it reorganizes things as necessary
in a process known as compilation making
the code more and more primitive until
finally it's translated into it set of
digital grunts called machine language
that's the sort of thing a computer can
execute and those grunts have become
just part of the furniture of your life
it's software that switches channels on
your TV how you can get money out of an
ATM how an elevator takes you up five
flights of stairs you write code and the
computer turns it into software and that
can run as many times as you need I'm
the president familiar invisible that is
the story of code